[Music]
then as I turned back to my work I
noticed something in the corner of my
eye something was standing in my room
now hello and welcome to old ain't a
creepypasta horror stories cooked to
perfection with a splash of red sauce my
name is Susie and I will be your server
in this episode today's stories are
perfect for a cosy night of studying
relaxing and getting the chills running
down your spine at the absolute horror
that's about to unfold make sure you get
comfortable and let's dig right in
listening to music has always been my
favorite part of winding down when I get
home every evening lately I have really
taken a liking to relaxing in my room
and jamming to some low fight chill
music every night before I go to bed
I'll toss on a youtube stream take back
and talk to strangers in the chat for a
while before logging out for the night I
always find it interesting how this
seems to be the only internet chat
section in the known universe or people
always get along I feel like the chill
music vibe has something to do with it
lately I've started to notice the same
group of people who tend to go online
every day around the same time would it
be too weird to call them my friends
even though we haven't met we all have
similar interests and it feels like we
can talk about anything
cowboy bebop old-school video games our
favorite youtubers even our most
disliked teachers I was chatting in the
stream at our usual time when a channel
popped into the conversation and wrote
the words roll call in all caps random
people started writing their location in
the chance Chicago Los Angeles Tokyo
figuring there is no harm in simply
putting a city I typed mine into the
chat and continued to read where the
others were from that's when I started
noticing that quite a few of my friends
were close by really close by I kind of
day dreamed about what it would be like
if we met in real life and as if to read
my mind one of the regulars in the
Chad's shadow hand 11:33 pointed out
that we were all actually really close
to each other one thing led to another
and I know this is a stupid idea but we
decided to meet up I justified it in my
head telling myself that we'd all spoken
to each other almost every night in the
Chad's it's not like anyone appeared out
of the blue and asked us to meets it
felt safe and they felt like friends
I'll just say this right now because I'm
sure you think you know where this is
going trusting the people I was talking
to online was not necessarily where I
went wrong in this story actually it may
have been my saving grace but there was
one other thing I overlooked that led to
what I can only describe as the scariest
encounter of my life after school I rode
my bike to the 7-eleven we all decided
to meet at around the edge of town I got
there a few minutes early sat on the
curb to wait for the others I had no
faces to look out for we actually only
knew each other by username so everyone
I saw walking in and out of the
convenience store was potentially one of
us and I was just imagining each new
face I saw linking up with a name but
over the course of the next 20 minutes
nobody approached me and I didn't see
any messages from the others even though
I tried hitting them up to see where
they were at I was beginning to think
that I was the only one who showed up
when I heard a voice behind me all right
I turned to see a man probably in his
late twenties or early thirties for some
reason I specifically remember his
figure shading my eyes and blocking out
the now Setting Sun are you part of the
wolf eye group I told him yes and let
him know both my youtube user name and
my real name he told me he was shadow
hand which I instantly recognized as the
one who had the idea for the meetup in
the first place I did notice that he
didn't mention his real name which was
only slightly weird because I had given
him my first name but understanding the
somewhat awkward nature of meeting
people from online I didn't press the
issue since I didn't want to ask
anything that might have made him
uncomfortable I had also expected
someone around the same age as me so
seeing that he was significantly older
was just a bit off-putting he told me
that the rest of the group was already
hanging out down the street I had one of
the girls houses and they had given me a
lift over there his car was parked on
the side of the 7-eleven and after
locking up my bike to a fence I followed
him over towards it I'm fully aware of
the dangers of getting into a stranger's
car so let me just clarify what was
going through my head at the moment the
first thing that came out of his mouth
when he approached me was about the low
fight group so it's not like I was just
getting picked up by some Rando there
were also several of us meeting up so
unless this guy made a bunch of youtube
accounts just to trick me into getting
into his car I
felt like there wasn't much of a threat
he opened the back door of his SUV I
received a message from one of the group
members it was from him from shadow hand
11:33 he said he was in front of the
7-eleven and he was asking if anyone was
here I froze in front of the open car
door I looked up at the guy then back
down at my phone did you send this he
said yes and tried to usher me into the
car but then for the first time that
afternoon something did not feel right I
turned back and looked at the front of
the store where I had been waiting
before there was a kid standing there
about my age looking at a phone what
happened next is still talked about to
this day the kid turned around and by
some stroke of luck spotted me and waved
I turned and waved back but before I
could tell the man who had offered me a
ride that there was somebody back by the
door of the convenience store I heard
the car door slam shut behind me this
guy literally ran to the driver's side
and before I even knew what had happened
he was in the car turning the ignition
and flooring it apart
something out of a bank robbery scene if
you haven't figured it out yet I'll
break it down for you the kid in front
of the 7-eleven was the real shadow hand
11:33 the man in the car was just
pretending to be him since it was a
recognizable name from the Chad's
we would later figure out that the man
with the car wasn't anyone from the
group who would agree to meet up but
because we had planned our get-together
on a public livestream anyone could see
it that was our big mistake
even though all of us were trustworthy
some random creepy noticed our
conversation and decided to take
advantage of it police would later
review the 7-eleven security footage to
see the man pull up several minutes
before I arrived hiding in his SUV along
the side of the building which was not
covered by any camera then upon
realizing I was the only one who had
showed up decided to make his move his
license plate was never visible on
camera due to the angle at which he
drove in while we do know he was one of
the people tuned into the livestream
that day the police had no way of
getting an actual list of IP addresses
or accounts who accessed it so to this
day he has never been caught I guess
there is one good thing that came out of
all of this though outside of me really
putting my guard up the real shadow hand
and I became very good friends and it's
always an interesting story when people
ask how we know each other and know that
isn't his real username I changed it for
this story because he can never be too
careful
he and I have spent many hours talking
about what might have happened to me if
he had gotten there was second later and
I had gotten into that car it sends
shivers down my spine thinking about
what that guy was planning to do or
where he was planning to take me in that
dark window to SUV of his I mean what
kind of kidnapper goes after a random
people and a YouTube stream anyway he
had no way of knowing who I was or even
that I would show up to the Meetup let
alone the fact that I was there by
myself that's the other thing we later
found out that the other kids we were
supposed to meet up with just didn't
show up and
I did not to let that group know that
they'd no longer be coming I can't say I
blame them for bailing considering what
almost happened but it would have been
nice if they'd given a heads-up as far
as the low five streams go yeah and I
still listen to them and partake in the
chat too it's not like I'd be in any
kind of danger just because some freak
knows my first name in my face but there
is something that still bothers me
through this entire experience every
time I write a message in the chat of
that stream before I press Enter
I think about the possibility that that
guy with the SUV is watching and reading
every message that I put out I was
planning on having my girlfriend over
that evening so I threw on some music
and got to cleaning the place I went
upstairs to get started on my room since
I figured we'd be spending most of our
time there as I was making my bed I
heard what sounded like someone
rummaging around downstairs I do leave
the door unlocked when she's coming over
but she wasn't supposed to come by for
another hour and a half and early is not
part of her vocabulary it took me a few
moments to realize that the song I was
listening to was sampling sound bites
what I thought I heard was all part of
the music I finished making my bed and
started folding some of the piles of
clothes that covered the majority of my
bedroom floor
[Music]
no no that had to be coming from
downstairs I paused the music and listen
more closely okay maybe I was right the
first time maybe it was just part of the
music I unpause dand sure enough the
sound that I thought I had heard was
looping in the song I got back to work
folding my clothes okay that was
definitely not part of the song I paused
the music yet again and just as it
paused I heard a door closed down below
I called out my girlfriend's name to try
to put an end to whatever prank she was
pulling down there
my heart stopped when I saw the scene at
the bottom of the stairs every single
closet cupboard and drawer was open and
the contents of each were thrown on the
ground my place had been ransacked the
strange part was nothing had been taken
as far as I can tell whoever was in my
house is looking for one thing in
particular and I had no idea what it was
I did a brief search on the ground floor
of my house but I didn't manage to turn
up anybody so I took a seat on the
stairs and dialed 9-1-1 that's when I
heard a noise coming from upstairs
behind me who's there
whoever had broken into my house had
inadvertently started playing my music
again or maybe it was on purpose I
honestly had no idea at this point I had
completely forgotten that I was on the
phone.i there's someone in my house I
explained the situation and they
recommended I get to a safe place such
as a neighbor's house while they sent
somebody out I might have been inclined
to stay and protect my belongings
however the intruder made it quite clear
he didn't really care about valuables so
for the better of my safety I took their
advice the intruder was never found and
nothing was taken from my house as far
as I could tell I don't leave the door
open for my girlfriend anymore
I made sure to copy her a key after that
night it's also made me a bit paranoid
whenever I listen to music I'm
constantly pausing if I hear anything
that doesn't sound instrumental and if I
even think I heard something
I'm sure to check all around the house
I'd take a night class on Wednesday
evenings at my university usually I take
a new bar home but I was running a bit
low on money and I decided to walk I
typically listen to music when I walk
hoodie up and earbuds in when you have
long hair like I do you got to keep it
dry there was a super light rain pour
that night not even enough to use an
umbrella but just enough to where it
felt like a nice cool mist with my hood
up so while I was just casually walking
home looking at the ground not really
paying much attention to my surroundings
I play this little game in my head where
I try to step on each sidewalk tile the
same amount of times so if I do it I
have like a perfectly paced walk or
something if you don't get it I probably
can't explain it to you anyway I was
looking down and all of a sudden I
nearly stepped in this huge open manhole
on the ground I jumped back and my
heart's beating out of my chest cuz I
nearly just fell down and broke my
freaking neck at the bottom of the
sewers who left the sewage cap open to
begin with naturally I had to look down
it it's not every day you get to see an
open manhole I turned on my phone's
flashlight and peered down inside what I
didn't expect to see was a pair of eyes
staring back up at me these eyes
squinted as if they hadn't seen light in
days but that wasn't the most disturbing
part the guy's head was shaved except
for maybe a three-inch diameter where
the hair was grown at about 12 inches or
so so the result was he was bald except
for this one masse tube of hair coming
out of the side of his head he wore a
dirty beige jacket and matching jeans he
also had huge dark bags underneath his
eyes and he immediately cowered away
from the lights and then hidden
the pipes down below not expecting to
see someone down there my heart skipped
to be and I pulled away from the rim of
the manhole who was that know what was
that maybe I was just overreacting
so there's a homeless guy who takes
shelter in the sewers he probably came
out because of all the rain we've been
getting and got a little spooked when I
saw him as for the haircut hard to
explain that one but he's living in the
sewers probably had some issues to begin
with that's just the sad truth of the
matter I got home took my shoes off
under the awning toss my hoodie in the
dryer it had gotten more damp than I had
thought over the course of the long walk
home I went on the computer for a bit
before going to bed and that's when I
passed out until I realized that my
ringtone was still on I want to turn it
off I had no interest in replying to the
message until I just happened to noticed
what it said in the preview panel it was
from my friend who lived in the dorms
across the way from me it said who's
that by your window what what was he
talking about
I reached over for the light switch
there was nothing at my window as far as
I could tell at least that's what I
thought at first and I do wish that was
the case my window is one of those with
a really strong glare during the day you
can see out from the inside but if you
try looking in from the outside it's
almost like looking in a mirror during
the night it's reversed to where it's
hard to see out from the inside but
Outsiders can see me provided the light
is on and the blinds are up which they
were although looking out was kind of
like looking through a mirror there was
an unmistakable outline of someone
standing on the other side there's only
one way to he had a better lookout and
to get your face close to the glass and
create a shade with your hands and
that's exactly what I did I wish I
hadn't because for the second time that
night I saw that terrifying wild pair of
eyes staring back at me I only looked
out of the window for a slight moment
before jumping back out of my skin and
screaming as I reached for my phone dial
campus security but what I saw in that
moment that it really makes me sick to
think about but I'll try to recount it
for the purposes of this story the man
at the window the sewer-dwelling man
from before didn't have a weird haircut
he was actually entirely bald but he had
several different colors of hair super
glued to his head in that one spot like
it was his collection or something
because I also spotted an object in his
right hand a rusty pair of scissors I
must have screamed the poor security
guy's ear off before promptly hanging up
and in an act of desperation pushing my
furniture up to barricade the door but
it wasn't the door I had to be worried
about because he started stabbing the
scissors into the window his taps got
harder and harder didn't seem like the
window would give much longer before
breaking I was frantically searching my
room for something to fight back with
but I didn't have much but tapping
stopped bright light flooded the area
and relief washed over me as the campus
security pulled up I couldn't hear or
see very much but from what I could tell
the security guard asked the guy a
couple questions which he promptly
ignored and continued to just stare
through my window the guard asked him to
leave and he did comply but what still
chills me is that he never took his eyes
off me the entire time he was being
escorted away until he was completely
out of sight the guard caught back up
with me later I told him the whole story
about the manhole he said I should be
careful when walking home with
headphones at night there have been a
few cases of people being followed home
by predators and not noticing because
they were wearing headphones usually
it's just some drunk weird I was going
after girls but as we saw tonight there
were just some weird people out there
and you can never be too careful there
wasn't much he can do since the guy was
on a public walkway and didn't really
break any law I always make sure to get
a ride home after night classes now I
haven't seen the guy since then and I
hope I never do
[Music]
ah yes there's nothing quite like the
smooth relaxing sounds of low phi when
it comes to getting some studying done
it's the jazzy chords the bass e
undertones the nostalgic samples
something about it is just too enticing
I don't even normally listen to hip-hop
when jamming out I normally like my
music to be fast and loud but when I'm
trying to be productive lyrics and
catchy riffs just distract me but with
lo-fi I can just melt away piles of work
without even realizing it it's just
something about the vibes you know what
I mean that atmosphere created by the
combination of the music and the sins of
adorable characters doing their thing on
a rainy day or a cloudy night even the
people in the chat of the live stream
seem to be so easygoing and friendly but
I try not to get distracted by that too
much so today I'm studying for a
neurological science exam we're studying
the effects of Pavlovian conditioning
and neural physiology
it's easily my favorite course we
sometimes do experiments to see if we
can train small rodents using the
concepts we study sometimes I'd like it
if my kid brother Kevin could be as
easily trained but I seriously doubt
that something like that will ever be
possible on any intelligent being
however low on the spectrum zet
intelligence may fall and what do you
know look who's right on cue hey bro
what you do studying oh okay
so yes Kevin I'm very busy oh that's
okay I just wanted to see if you wanted
to go to Robo pizza later they're having
it okay look I've got an exam on Monday
and I'm already really tired well maybe
another time
well of course you're tired being cooped
up here listening to this MOBA music all
day hey you know it's not moping music
you just but before I could even finish
objecting he in true rodent fashion
scampered into my room and pounced on my
laptop without permission nor regret
okay
looked eV you know what I'll take you to
your dang pizza place if you get out now
and leave me alone for the next hour in
the time it took him to say the word
deal he scattered out of my room and
slammed the door behind him and try not
to touch anything on your way out well I
bought an hour to myself and to be
totally fair I actually didn't mind the
future funk playlist he clicked on it
actually did wake me up a little bit by
the end of the night I was feeling okay
about my chances on the test but I still
had some other homework to finish up so
the following night I found a good loaf
ice cream and time to get in the zone
and knock this thing out now this next
part I don't fully know how to describe
I was so in the zone doing this mindless
work that it was almost like I was
asleep and without me really realizing
it the music began to get more and more
disturbing off-key and just downright
unsettling but it happened so gradually
that I almost didn't notice it until it
was eating it my anxiety the music that
once relaxed me was now putting me on a
very uncomfortable edge and for some
reason well I didn't have the sense of
mind to stop it it was like I was
trapped in an unbreakable loop of
tedious work my body wanted to snap out
of it so bad but my mind wouldn't come
up with the commands to go through with
it then for some unknown reason I looked
at my laptop screen where the chill hop
string was playing and what I saw
affected me so badly I felt as if I
couldn't even breathe in place of the
kawaii anime girl doing her homework was
some kind of demon a demon whose eyes
pierced through my soul so badly that I
couldn't look away to end the suffering
it was causing it curled its smile in
the most unimaginable way it almost made
me sick it was like it was looking at me
specifically and and it was enjoying
putting me in this trance-like state I
don't remember what exactly happened
after that the next thing I knew I was
standing in my little brother's doorway
unable to recall how or why I was
standing there
Tevin was staring back at me from his
bed with a confused expression on his
face bro bro what are you doing I uh how
long have I been standing here I don't
know I was just playing the switch and I
randomly noticed you spacing out at my
door I've been trying to wake you up for
like two whole minutes I cringed at my
own unawareness I'm sorry I just forgot
why it came in here okay are you on
drugs no what no of course not I just
forgot why he came in here I'm just
really tired I guess not knowing what
else to say and feeling slightly
embarrassed for myself I headed back to
my room I figured maybe I was right
maybe I did just need some sleep
the next day at school I felt like I had
totally recovered and you know what
I killed the science test honestly like
I felt like I knew every single answer
and it was overall a really good day the
teacher had assigned a new project so
after school I went straight back to
work
Tevin blabbered something about him
wanting me to take him somewhere as soon
as I walked through the door but I
firmly told him that I had a lot of work
to do for starters I didn't even have a
topic for my project so I needed to find
some ideas I went to go turn on some
music when suddenly I remembered about
yesterday
the lo-fi the demon the randomly finding
myself and my brother's room I typed
lo-fi into youtube to see what would
turn up and found the same string from
yesterday what appeared on the screen
before me seemed normal so I looked into
the chat to see if there was anything
suspicious I don't know what I thought I
was gonna find but there were just some
kids having casual conversation nothing
major
I started to realize how ridiculous I
was being I figured I just fell asleep
and sleep walked into my brother's room
one of our uncle's was a known
sleepwalker when he was younger so it
didn't seem that crazy to me but before
I could breathe a sigh of relief
something began to sound kind of off
about the music I looked back at my
screen the demon from before was back
and its eyes were locked on mine it's
cold stare petrified me it reached out
towards me it felt like it was literally
reaching out of the screen though I
don't really believe that's actually
possible it couldn't be for whatever
reason I didn't move I didn't scream I
didn't click away to another video
nothing I was frozen I felt like it was
gonna get me and that I would never be
able to come back and that's all I
remember the next thing that can
recollect was being in a dark room not
knowing where the hell I was and
wondering where it had taken me my eyes
began to adjust and what I saw before me
was a face a face of horror it was my
brother lying on his bed terrified
looking like he was about to scream
bloody murder why was i standing over
his bed how how did I end up here
what what are you doing I I don't know I
think I've been sleepwalking
what he told me next chilled me right to
my core but hey your eyes were open you
had the scariest look on your face I
when I saw you like that I thought you
were gonna hurt me I was shocked that he
would say such a thing i sat down on his
bed Ted I you know I would never hurt
you promise of course not I I would
never even think about it I honestly
don't remember anything until I woke up
right here oh hey he didn't sound
terribly convinced but I told him to go
back to bed and asked him to let me know
if he caught me sleepwalking again it
was late I knew this would probably be
an all-nighter I mean I still had a ton
of homework to get done I also felt that
I should probably do it without the
assistance of lo fight strings on
YouTube you know just to play it safe
but when I went back into my room and
looked over all the work I had left I
realized every single assignment was
done my science project was done too for
the first time in my academic career I
was ahead the next day of school was
crazy I got my test back a plus 102
percent
I had nailed every question and the
extra credit in every class I knew every
question the teacher asked and I know
this is gonna sound crazy but sometimes
I need the question the teacher was
gonna ask before she even asked it any
chance that I'd be studying too any
other sound but the sound of the low
five string that night was now out the
window when I got home I logged my door
hopefully that would keep me from
sleepwalking into anyone's room
and of course I was afraid I might see
that demon thing again but at this point
that didn't really matter I figured it
was worth it the strain was waiting for
me in my recommended list I clicked on
it opened a book and started reading
several minutes went by nothing happened
possibility started floating through my
head like maybe it doesn't work if
you're expecting it or you know maybe it
was a time thing I mean I was studying
earlier than I did on previous nights
but yeah I cranked up the volume until
it was as loud as it would go
still no effect I figured my best bet
was just to try studying as normal and
if it happens it at that moment I heard
that familiar sound things were getting
weird again with the audio I looked up
at the screen expecting to see that
demon staring back at me but what I saw
instead was a large empty room it was
the same room that the anime girl was
usually studying in but it was just
empty then as I turned back to my work I
noticed something in the corner of my
eye something was standing in my room
now which I quickly realized was
impossible because my door was locked
the figure stepped forward and what I
saw what I saw was a life-sized version
of the demon from my computer screen
grinning at me I fell back out of my
chair and slammed on the ground I've
never been so scared I tried to scramble
away but somehow it was standing over me
smiling with that devilish smile
I can't even properly describe it the
mouth opening was probably whiter than a
football all I could do was flail as it
begin to smother me I could hear its
growl take over the sound of the string
darkness surrounded me as I could fill
the demon hitting me in the chest arms
in the face the growl turned into a
screech
what I saw before me horrified and
disgusted me it was Tevin on his badge
again but this time with a pair of hands
clinched tightly around his throat it
didn't take long for me to realize the
horror of the situation they were my
hands yeah I was choking my little
brother with my own hands I could hear
the screen playing audibly from the
other room I had no control over myself
I had my brother pinned down on his bed
and I was forcing the air out of him
suddenly a flash of light filled the
room as the door slammed open my father
quickly assessed the situation and I was
thrown off violently I've never seen him
act so aggressively in my entire life
and it felt horrible seeing him treat me
so violently that was definitely a rough
night actually it was the beginning of a
rough couple of months luckily my
brother was okay the police came and of
course nobody believed my side of the
story I ended up being sent away for a
while but with no incidents and no sign
of mental illness thankfully my stay in
the institution didn't last long the
next year I was back in school as normal
thankfully I had disappeared near the
end of the year so not too many people
even noticed that I was gone one day in
the fall my curiosity and lack of
closure got the better of me and I muted
my computer and tried to find the string
that had supposedly set me off I mean I
have no intention of actually listening
to it I just wanted to report it after a
search that ended up giving me nothing I
decided to look back at my browser
history and there it was I gulped was it
really a good idea to click on this link
after several months even with no
incidents I just had to know
404 the pager trying to access does not
exist I was confused there was an
important distinction it didn't say that
the stream had been deleted or that the
channel had been taken down according to
what it said nothing ever existed in the
first place I decided it wasn't worth
wasting my life on so I closed the
laptop and forgot about it that was my
last experience with lo fight for the
next two years I made the effort to
avoid it whenever I could I was at my
first college party I didn't usually go
to parties but my friend had convinced
me that this one would be a pretty
laid-back gig I guess I shouldn't have
been surprised to hear the sounds of low
fight chill hop pumping through the
speakers I took a deep breath okay I can
handle this it's just music at a party
if I need to dip outside I can I
composed myself and walked into the
party with my friend thanks for
listening to all daint a creepypasta
your total today comes out to $11.33 but
if you like this video right now I'll
waive that fee and give you everything
you just listened to absolutely free
big thanks to mr. blacks audio animation
for narrating that last story if you're
a fan of all daint a creepypasta you'll
definitely want to subscribe to mr.
blacks channel by clicking here he is
the best at telling his stories through
his own style of immersive sound design
he calls it audio animation and you
definitely need to hear it as you heard
in this episode music was a huge part of
these stories the original score was
composed by OST maker and the end theme
you're hearing now is
by neo yasaku matzoh links to all these
channels are available in the credit
section at the bottom of the description
let me know what your favourite story
was from this episode in the comments
and remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds from new Horrors every week ring
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]